[Música]
la Casa Blanca dio un plazo de 30 días a
sus funcionarios para que eliminen de
sus dispositivos la red social de tiktok
de origen chino la decisión que le
siguió a países como Canadá o los socios
de la Unión Europea obedece a temores de
que el gigante asiático pueda espiarlos
o recopilar datos además de adoctrinar a
favor de Beijing cuánto crédito se puede
dar a estos riesgos y cómo corresponde
china nos lo cuenta Maximiliano cantix
quien es el director de operaciones de
séptica y además está en el estudio
Daniel hablandon nuestra periodista de
economía Un saludo para usted
Maximiliano Daniela y pues vamos a
empezar si les parece con las preguntas
de una vez Maximiliano tiktok es el
segundo dominio más popular del mundo
solamente en Estados Unidos es consumido
por dos tercios de sus adolescentes la
decisión Estatal toca de alguna manera
la ciudadanía
a ver buenos buenos días gracias por la
invitación este
depende el enfoque no hay que hay que
entender que las redes sociales
además de brindarnos todo el servicio
que que nos brindan no estamos hablando
de servicios para conseguir trabajo para
estar en contactos con gente conocida en
el fondo son de herramientas para la
recolección de datos sí se recolectan
muchos datos Y esos datos el miedo en
algunos casos es justamente ver qué van
a hacer con esa información y creo que
este es uno de los puntos centrales de
esta crítica no a la red social
Maximiliano podría también así como
accidente teme que china recopile datos
y los use a su favor podría también
China o una persona del común temer que
empresas como Facebook o Twitter también
recopilen datos y los usen a favor de sí
mismas o a favor de los gobiernos
bueno recordemos que ahora el foco está
puesto en tiktok Pero recuerda que en el
2016 hubo todo un lío con Facebook y
Cambridge analítica que terminaron
vinculando todo esto con las elecciones
de de Donald no que finalmente ganó
Entonces esto de las redes sociales
involucradas en temas políticos por la
información que manejan no es algo nuevo
Lo que pasa que ahora tiktok al ser la
dueña una empresa China y al estar los
datos por ejemplo de la comunidad
europea en China se teme justamente por
el acceso a esos datos de qué datos
estamos hablando bueno piensen que la
aplicación al estar instalada en el
teléfono tiene acceso a por ejemplo a la
localización GPS es decir puede saber la
aplicación en donde estamos tienen
acceso a los contactos tienen acceso a
la información del dispositivo que
estamos utilizando y todo esto junto
bueno son datos y multipliquemos la por
millones son datos importantes entonces
creo que el tema de las redes sociales
está vinculada al tema político desde
hace un tiempo ya
Sigamos hablando de ese tema político en
2020 recordemos que Donald Trump intentó
prohibir el uso total es de tiktok y
forzar a la compañía a vender sus
activos en Estados Unidos esta
iniciativa finalmente fue bloqueada por
tribunales pero en este gobierno ha
dicho que va a volver a revisar las
políticas en torno a tiktok usted cree
que habría posibilidades de que avanzara
una legislación En ese sentido así como
por ejemplo fue prohibido WhatsApp en
China
bueno el tema Ángela de las
legislaciones saquemos este tema porque
el tema político es como que distorsiona
tal vez la información que la gente
necesita tener Y es que es necesario
tener regulaciones para el manejo de
datos de los ciudadanos sí es importante
que los gobiernos se metan y puedan
definir qué Cuál es el alcance del
manejo de esos datos y que estas
compañías sean abiertas en el momento de
contar dónde estás información quién
tiene acceso cómo la van a utilizar
ahora después cuando entra el tema
político bueno por la pregunta es por
qué se prohíbe tiktok y no otras
herramientas que hacen cosas parecidas
no no me quiero quiero decir no me
quiero meter el tema político pero digo
hay una un tema
arbitrario en decir este sigue este no y
ahí es donde los ciudadanos quedamos en
el medio no
y hay otro tema y es la letra pequeña
finalmente nosotros como usuarios
También estamos
metiéndonos en estas redes sociales
inscribiéndonos y estamos entregando
muchos datos que ni siquiera nosotros
mismos sabemos que estamos entregando
Cuál es el llamado también para las
personas a que a que miren bien qué es
lo que están firmando antes de meterse
en una de estas redes sociales
Mira Daniela hace poco vi un informe de
un ingeniero que analizó hizo ingeniería
reversa de tiktok no
y ingeniería reversa es como analizó
técnicamente bien como como se maneja
esta herramienta y dice que lejos de ser
una red social Es una herramienta que
recopila abiertamente información de las
personas Entonces
desde nuestro lugar tenemos que entender
que estar en internet es resignar
privacidad ahora el tema es Cuánta de
nuestra privacidad queremos resignar
bueno Ahí es donde depende mucho de
nosotros cuando tenemos que leer en el
momento de instalar una aplicación que
es lo que va a ser la aplicación ya sé
que eso son son
como explicaciones muy largas pero
tenemos que involucrarnos y ver qué van
a hacer con nuestros datos antes de
instalarla y también la recomendación
desde safety a nosotros como compañía y
estamos especializados en el tema de
privacidad es
va a estar todo el tiempo subiendo a
internet lo que estamos haciendo a dónde
nos vamos de vacaciones este estamos
comiendo con quién estamos Esa esa
sobreexposición que tenemos Bueno
regularlo un poco lo que se llama en
inglés el over sharing no esto de
compartirlo todo
pues Maximiliano gracias a usted porque
nos aclara un poco todos los temas en
torno a la privacidad Gracias Daniela
también y bueno Vamos a continuar con
más en directo América vamos a una
pequeña pausa y ya regresamos
[Música]